بالفعل نحن لا نزلنا امام مركز للايواء
الذي يعني تتوافد اليه السيارات التي تنقل
السوريين الذين تقطعت بهم السبل بعد ان
انهدمت منازلهم ولكن الان للتو يعني
التقيت صدفه بهذا الشاب وبيني وبينه حكايه
قبل ايام كنت التقيته وسط
انطاكيا الى جانب بنايه وكان يجلس وفي
جانبه جثث مجهوله الهويه وكانت ساعات
متاخره من الليل توقفت وتحدثت اليه
واخبرني بانها جثث خرجت من مبنى ولا
يعرفون لمن تعود وكان موقف يعني
مؤثر جدا لانه كان وبصحبته
ناشطين يبحثون عن اي شخص يتعرف على هذه
الجثث الان شاهدته للصدفه وذكرني بنفسه
وانا اشكره ولذلك موضوع الجثث مجهوله
الهويه وما الذي يحدث معها امر هام جدا
لذلك اسمحي لي ان
اتجه قليلا في الحوار الى هذا الشاب عن
هذا الامر اولا بدي اذكرك بالقصه انت
تذكرتها جيدا في حينه لمن عادت تلك الجثث
الاربعه التي رايتها انا لمين طلعت اجا
اخوها
اخوه للشاب وهو
بيكون اخوه وزوجته واثنين اطفال اجا اخونا
الشاب يتعرف عليهم وكيف عرفوا الاسره
بوجودهم كيف اندلوا انه انتم عندكم الجثث
هنا اجوا على الموقع البناء معه العنوان
عارف يعني وين اخوه ساكن اتطلع تدلع على
البنايه بيعرفوا انه هاي البنايه ساكن
فيها ناس
اخوه ومرت اخوه وكلهم طبعا طلعوا
تعرف عليهم وعرف انهم
كانت عباره عن ثلاث طواب اغلب سكانها من
السوريين كل الضحايا لقيناهم ببيت الدرج
الا الاخت اللي كانت تعادل عنا لقيناها
لسه طبعا مطبقه على اخر البنايه
هيك الحال عم يصير كل الناس اللي واقف له
قرايبين عم يجوا يوقفوا عند بنايتهم
ويجيبوا فرق الانقاذ والاليات انا كنت شفت
الجثه تبقى 24 ساعه جنب البنايه اذا اجت
حدا تعرف عليها بياخذها ما اجابته يروح
لمقبره الارقام للمقبره الجديد تدفن بعد
تصويرها مع رقم صحيح وهذول الناس هذا اللي
حدث معهم انت بتقولي لثاني يوم في جثث ظلت
لثاني يوم قال لسه باقي العيله ما طلعت من
تحت الانقاذ بالسنه مشان ياخذوه من عائله
كامله او انه ما تعرف عليها تستنى لتاني
يوم الصبح بعدين بكملوا بكون انت الان عدت
من هناك لسه في جثث بتطلع كم
اعداد كبيره نحن شلون طريقه البحث راح
تكون بيعطونا مثلا بخابرونا بيقولوا لنا
انه بالمجموعات انه فيها هذا العنوان في
عيله سبع اشخاص مثلا او شخصين مفقودين وما
عملاقيهم بالمشاكل بنروح بدنا ناخذ منه
عنوان صحيح
نعيط الاليات نعرض نعيط فرق الانقاذ خلونا
نقرب
تامن على حالي عبر الواتساب او حدا نداء
تروحوا للموقع بتبحثوا الجثث وبتخرجوها
وبتيجي الناس تتعرف عليها واذا في حال ما
تعرفوا عليها شو بتعملوا نوديها
عند المقابر والمقابر الجديده ايوه موجود
هونيك يعني النائب العام يصورها وبعطيها
رقم وبيعتمدات اذا ما في ما حدا متعرف
عليه ما بيعملوا شهاده وفاه
بيستنوا لحتى يمكن تخلصوا الازمه او
يتجاوزوها اشكرك جدا